we have news of a major break in a cold
case stretching back almost 25 years
police have now carried out multiple
search warrants in two states in
connection with the disappearance of
Kristin smart a 19 year old college
freshman in California smart was
declared legally dead in 2002 her body
has never been found
Mireya Villarreal reports this home in
San Pedro California is one of four
location searched by authorities this
week in connection with the 1996
disappearance of Kristin smart a man
believed to be 43 year-old Paul Flores
was held outside as sheriff's removed
multiple items of interest he was not
arrested or charged I refused to answer
that question
Laura's pleaded the fifth when
interviewed by authorities after smart
vanished and has denied involvement in
her disappearance police believe he was
the last person seen with her after a
party as they walked on the campus of
Cal Poly University nearly 24 years ago
sheriff's also issued search warrants
for the home of Flora's mother and
another unspecified location both in San
Luis Obispo County in addition to a
fourth location in Washington state the
Flores family declined our request for
comment
in a statement sheriff's say the search
warrants are sealed by the court
we are precluded by law from disclosing
any further details in a radio interview
Thursday the san luis obispo sheriff
pointed out that DNA testing has greatly
improved since kristen smart first
disappeared what they did in an
investigation is different from what we
do now what we have available now what
our focus is now for CBS this morning
media vol Los Angeles huge if there's a
break in that case after 24 years family